أنت تنظر إلى صورة درامية للغاية
لطلاب يختبئون على حافة أحد المباني
بينما يقوم مسلح
بإطلاق النار بشكل مميت في إحدى جامعات
براغ، مما أسفر عن مقتل ما لا يقل عن 14 شخصًا وإصابة 25
آخرين خلال ما
وصفه رئيس جمهورية التشيك
بـ  الحادثة الأكثر مأساوية في
تاريخ البلاد ميليسا بيل من شبكة سي إن إن تروي
قصة الرعب في شوارع
طلاب براغ الذين يخاطرون بحياتهم هربًا من
رصاص مسلح أدى إلى مقتل أكثر من
اثني عشر شخصًا بعد
ظهر الخميس، وأصيب أكثر من 20 شخصًا، 10 منهم
خطيرة في إطلاق النار في براغ
جامعة تشارلز قبل أن يتم القضاء على المسلح وهو
طالب فلسفة مسجل،
قالت الشرطة إنه هجوم
هز
جمهورية التشيك، لا يوجد أي
تفسير على الإطلاق ولا مبرر لهذا
مثل الكثير منكم، أشعر بحزن عميق
واشمئزاز من هذا
العنف الوحشي وغير المفهوم مثل الليل  سقطت على براغ
ظهرت تفاصيل عن المشتبه به البالغ من العمر 24 عامًا
قبل إطلاق النار المميت في
العاصمة، وقالت الشرطة إن مطلق النار غادر
قريته حيث تم العثور على والده
ميتًا عازمًا على إراقة المزيد من الدماء، وشق
طريقه إلى العاصمة التشيكية وأبلغ
قوات الشرطة.  سارع الطلاب إلى إخلاء
المبنى الذي كان من المقرر أن
يحضر فيه مطلق النار الانتخابات
لكنه ضرب مكانًا آخر مما أجبر الطلاب
على تحصن أنفسهم داخل
الفصول الدراسية، وتم إجلاؤهم لاحقًا بشكل جماعي استعدادًا
لامتحانات نهاية العام
بوحشية.
الإرهاب أكد وزير الداخلية التشيكي
ولكن الليلة مدينة في حالة صدمة في
قارة حيث عمليات إطلاق النار الجماعية قليلة
ومتباعدة